[Music]
but why some say the moon
why choose this as our goal
and they may well ask why climb the
highest mountain
five 35 years ago
fly the atlantic
we choose to go to the moon and do the
other thing
not because they are easy
but because they are hard
[Music]
[Music]
uh
james
fate
draws us back together
now your enemy is my enemy
how did that happen
well you live long enough
harder to tell the good from bad
villains from heroes these days
we used to be able to get into a room
with the enemy
now they're just floating in the ether
she still loves you did you know that
what is it
is she one of them i don't know her at
all
when her secret finds its way out
it'll be the death of you
james want
we both eradicate people
to make the world a better place
i just want to be a little
tidier
i met your new double oh
she's a disarming young woman
you've never flown one of these things
before
nope
come on bond where the hell are you
if we don't do this
there will be nothing left to say
when you're ready you're late
can i just have one nice evening please
before the world explodes
thomas
[Music]
you seem particularly triggered right
now can you tell me what happened
i've had dreams that weren't just dreams
am i crazy
we don't use that word in here
[Music]
hi
have we met
[Music]
one kill makes you larger and
one pill makes you small
and the ones that mother gives you
don't do
anything
at all
[Music]
when she's 10 feet tall
time to fly
[Music]
[Music]
the only thing that matters to you is
still here i know it's why you're still
fighting
and why you will never give up
you don't know me
no
dead
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
see
after all these years to be going back
to where it all started
back to the matrix
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
when i was young something happened to
me
i'm just not saying that daddy
who are you talking to
gabriel
is he your imaginary friend
whatever you went through before you
joined our family it hurt you in a way
that i can't even imagine
you created him daddy
what's going on
so that you could survive
i wanted to do something that was a bit
different but yet huck back to my roots
you got to take chances if you don't you
end up making the same old thing again
and again and again
i think audience is our star for
something that's new and different
[Applause]
are going to turn back the hands of time
close your eyes
he's there too
who is
[Music]
gabriel
who is gabriel
i'm the only one that can see him
that's him
he wants to talk to you
[Applause]
malignant
radar september 10th
what am i gonna get an android up here
can you really put a value on human life
an asteroid two miles wide will fly by
earth the public is being warned not to
panic something follows me i see it all
the time
stop living in my past
you are basically going to sleep
while his mind takes us over your body
it's easier to live in an illusion
not everyone is blessed with the luxury
of eternal life
god
how many sins have i committed this
month nine sins this month
i won't know what he's thinking about
leading up there all by
hours himself minutes left good luck
with your thoughts and prayers man
turn off
time just becomes more precious
[Music]
come on come on have some fun fun
[Music]
i have never felt more alive my entire
life
what do you want richard i'll be honest
with you i want money
i want to do a good deed
[Music]
i want to do a lot more
the best things in life are free i
haven't set an example from my nephew
them to the bed
anthony got kicked out of school i went
through all that trouble and for what
i've always been accused you're gonna be
good that's what i want i want to do
whatever i can to help the family
money don't get everything it's true
what it don't get i can't use i want
money
i wonder what they talk about in there i
didn't catch the name [ __ ]
put them on the
i
think
table
just got this jacket
[Music]
you know i try so hard
gotta do something about thinking
[Music]
i know you can get anything look at
dickie molten sandy he steps up takes
care of his family takes care of all the
business
does anybody tell anybody about this
how you doing on your merry badges
i want to do all kinds of good things
it's the one thing
[Music]
pain comes from always wanting things
but what do i know
i'm a murderer
the best things in life are free
got myself a son hi christopher hello
[Music]
like a scam or something some babies
when they come into the world know all
kinds of things from the other side
[Music]
i've been chasing their boss forever
this might go south
hell of a day isn't it partner
[Music]
[Applause]
up here
go go go
[Music]
you better go [ __ ] don't you touch my
baby
come on big boy come on
you all need to leave
please
who are you i'm a cop these two just
shot my partner down the road
run
i need you to get to safety these people
will kill you this is my farm they don't
belong here
who are these guys they're drug dealers
scumbags you're my prisoner until my
boss gets here i'm finishing this alone
i will defend this land
this is certainly a development
you came here to kill or did any of you
not get the memo on that
because evidently this cop did
i expect you and i aren't so different
nothing like you i got shot today and
i'm tied up
and you still hit like a [ __ ]
you need my help that's the house that i
shared with my wife
that is all i've got left all right
let's go save them
i got you back
we killed
or be killed
run i gotta finish this
runner arrest wrong place wrong time i'm
gonna be the guy that's gonna kill you
i'm not going anywhere
this is my farm
because you were number one once does
not mean you will be again i will be
number one
who are you i'm kate
i'm here to win the prize
they pick one girl and one boy for the
contract for the paris opera ballet
she's testing you
she's torturing me too
anyone who partners with lee bae will be
the better dancer he's the key to the
price
maybe you could help
me you always follow the rules
no
prove it
my heart is out of fire i'm gonna catch
three and we're gonna both stop why
should i trust you
one
two
three
[Music]
to win the prize together
but not at all
you win or not
i mean
[Music]
[Music]
what kind of game are you trying to play
made me think you were actually friends
i would never purposefully hurt you
so it's been about sex
blood
money
it's all that matters
[Music]
greatness has a price
do you agree
[Music]
i'm surrounded by idiots
i am completely different from my family
why is she avoiding us they're both
growing up so fast pretty hot hey ladies
i have the very solution we are going on
a family vacation
let's roam
you've always wanted to see more of this
great country
right in the niagara falls
hi what's your talent
there's my little holy terror
i remember the night wednesday was born
it was a tuesday she was silent that's a
jellyfish and i put all the babies back
where i found them huh i think
[Music]
we need to stop that family so the truth
can come out
who is that man no one at all do you
this trip will bring the atoms closer
than ever before
or there will be no survivors
it's just us and the wonderful sound of
silence
[Music]
[Music]
it
good to see you my big whisker cousin
i still don't understand the word that
guy say
[Music]
okay how high can you go
300
okay i want you to count to 600 i'll be
back
[Music]
survive anything because they stuck
together
now you tell me if we don't stand by
each other we can't get through anything
i know it yet
[Music]
we all have a story to tell
but what makes each one different
is not how the story ends
but rather the place where it begins
[Music]
oh holy god
my mom says if we went across the water
they wouldn't understand the way we talk
if they can't understand you then
they're not listening
you know who you are would you
your buddy from belfast where everybody
knows you
hey buddy
[Music]
we're looking to cleanse the community
away but you wouldn't want to be the old
man out in the street
talk to my family and i'll kill you
so we're gonna have to leave belfast
we'll fight this together
this is what this is war
[Music]
the same day as just ours are getting
killed we can give these boys a better
job so we ever
[Music]
go
had
don't look back
we need relevant writers that can make
us relevant again is there anyone dead
we can revive maybe but he's not dead
who
harry shaw
he's dead back her off
it's dragon
really i mean he probably
did you know he shot his last assistant
because he mistook him for a bear oh
how is that even possible i don't
believe you can't believe everything oh
we're not bears we're not bears we asked
danbridge publishing believe that is
your signature so you owe us a book shut
up
anything you want to show me
your pound of flesh i won't do the
bloody tour do the tour or i edit the
book those are your choices
this is a book toy why don't i read
something
no one's interested in the book they're
interested in this freak show this man
is the book reviewer for the times i
don't like book critics and i found it
totally past the next day
it is not selling okay no one is buying
it i can't get him to do anything all i
am to him is his driver and his scotch
sherpa let's go you want to buy a book
you want to know what i think
[Music]
times have changed hashtags both sides
how a book is released today has become
just as meaningful as its content eden
was gone no longer within reach god was
done with mistakes
it was too melodramatic
you vanquished my fears and for that
i am forever grateful this may be nuts
hasn't he
i know
[Music]
mr shaw what is your book about be brave
be truthful
even the worst of us get lucky
somehow you have over 20 000 followers
christ had followers it didn't end well
for him bible was the best seller wasn't
it
there's two kinds of people dad
the ones who have a bee bot
and the ones who don't hey guys oh sorry
i'm in your shot oh i have a filter for
that
really you need a bee bot to have a
social life yeah dad kind of i don't
want you addicted to some device
yeah though
hi barney i'm your best friend out of my
box
what are you doing
barney your bee bot is like super weird
i am barney's bee bop will you come to
my secret shed and like him
no no no
no
okay ron a bunch of your code is missing
you're supposed to know everything about
me hair brown height 411 511 would be
better girls would not laugh at you hey
making friends is what he's for friend
request friend request if he can't do
that he's like literally pointless oh
rose is pulling my head off you can't
pull his head up we'll get in trouble
okay i cannot pull his head off
i have no mega safety controls and stuff
copy him find that code
i'd better look into that you think
i'm not leaving you behind
they will send you to the crusher we'll
go to the crusher together no crushing
is not funny
not fun
where is it find the rogue we don't need
anyone else i currently have one friend
that is sad and also tragic
both of you is
[Music]
maybe turn it off and on again
[Music]
i got a bad feeling about this
what is this place
castle vader the galaxy's first
all-inclusive luxury theme resort feel
the power of the dark side at the empire
emporium now
[Music]
within these walls lies tales almost too
terrifying to tell would you like to
hear them
why is that lightning inside
oh that's a big one
the legendary tales of the sith speak of
the thirst for powers oh no join us
and take what you want
this isn't funny the devotion of the
a tale of desire i wish i was a pilot
join the imperial academy i will treat
you oh yeah
is that really what happened no it's not
be afraid be very afraid
[Music]
so what do you think
a little on the news is what i think
everyone gets scared kid
without fear you can't have courage
ears
b1496 1138
[Music]
[Music]
foreign